So I want to conclude this lesson by providing a high
level view of this scrum process. The process is represented here,
and as you can see it has several components. We're going to
go through all of them one at a time. We're going to
start with a product backlog. Product backlog is the single source
of requirements, for the process. They're order by value raised priority
necessity, so that all of this characteristics can be taken into
account when selecting which backlog items to consider for the next iteration.
It's a living list in the sense that backlog items
can be added or removed. And it's not really defined
as we just said, by the product owner. In the
sprint planning, what happens is that the next increment or
the next sprint is defined. So basically, the backlog items
of interest are selected based on the characteristics we just
mentioned: value, [UNKNOWN], priority, and necessity. And the items are
converted into tasks and estimated. So the result is this sprint
backlog, which is the set of backlog items that will
be completed during the next sprint. The sprint is an actual
iteration of this scrum process. It's got a main part
that lasts two to four weeks, and within this main part,
there are many daily scrums that last 24 hours. So
let's see how this work. A daily scrum is typically characterized
by a 50-minute meeting at the beginning of the day
for the team to sync, and what happens during the meeting
is that there is a discussion of the accomplishments since
the last meeting. A to do list for the next
meeting is produced, and there is also an obstacle analysis.
So if some problem appear, they're discussing the daily scrum, and
possible solutions are proposed. At the end of the two
four-week cycle, there is a sprint review and retrospective. The sprint
review normally consists of a four hour meeting. In the
meeting, the product owner assesses the accomplishment for the specific sprint,
and the team discusses issues that were encountered and solved.
There is typically a demo of the deliverable for that
sprint. And at that point, the product owner will also
discuss the backlogs. And together with the team they will decide
what to do next. In the retrospective conversely what happens
is there is more focus on the process. So the
goal of that part of the meeting is discussing possible
process improvements. To identify them
and if promising improvements are identified
try to plan how to implement those improvements and use them
in the next iterations. And something else that might happen at
the end of a sprint is that if the product increment
is good enough as it reach the state in which it
can be actually shipped that will result in a release that
is not just internal. To show the product owner the progress
that can also be deployed and actually used in production. So
one final consideration is that as you can see, XP and scrum
are fairly similar, and that's because they're both agile development
processes. So the main thing to keep in mind is that
they both implement and enforce
those ideas, values, practices, and characteristics
that we saw when we discussed agile development process in general.